scott's in philadelphia hey scott how
are you
i'm doing well how are you doing dave
better than i deserve how can we help
all right well i've been listening to
you guys since i would say about
february or march
and in january i did something very
stupid as i think you would say
um i bought a brand new car for uh to
the 238 thousand dollars so
i'm calling you to see if you think that
this is something that i can
afford and hold on to or if it's
something that you think i need to dump
right out right away and you know buy
something cheaper
okay so you said it's a 38 000 car
yeah brand brand new so yeah now it's
worth 32.
i got that and um you've been listening
to us
since january or no since february um
yes yes so what is the formula you tell
me
so i current so i currently make no
what's the form yeah yeah
go ahead you're good you're on it okay
yeah so i mean so i the car is about
just shy of 50 of my annual income which
i know is very steep
um and i've definitely been a car junkie
for a while now for a couple years it's
in the first time but
i make about you know like you can do
the math here i make about 80 000
a year on average i work in sales so it
varies um
and i have a good you know i feel like i
have a good um savings i don't own a
house
i rent um i have about six thousand in
the mutual fund
um that is managed professionally i have
21 and a 401 k
um and split between checking brokerage
and physical cash i have
about 100 000. um but i
i still owe 17.5 on the car so you know
i feel like i could
um pay the car off and still be in a
good spot but do you think
you know the car is too expensive for me
to own given my income and where i'm at
now
or do you think it's something that you
know i can continue to enjoy
there's two rules of thumb we use is it
less than half your annual income your
answer is
barely and the other rule of thumb is
can you be debt-free other than your
home within two years and still keep the
car
and the answer is yes so can you keep
the car
you got a really good cash position
that helps you with the barely right
so the question you need to ask yourself
and this is only one you can answer
is um uh you told me
and i'm the same way by the way but what
i heard you say is
cars are a problem area for you
if you if you reach and pay this call if
you reach and pay this car off
and keep it can you make it the last
time you do something stupid with an
automobile
if you can't you need to sell it to
prove to yourself
that you're not going to do stupid
anymore no i think it's the last dumb
car car uh purchase i make after finding
your guy's show i
i think it might be about it in the
first place yeah but you you're the only
one can answer that question
no you're right dave boy scott
buddy you got to make a decision and
here's what the other thing you got to
dig in and get serious and get this
thing
this payment out of your life yeah just
write a check he's got a hundred
thousand he got 17 0's yeah
write to check tonight keep the car and
then
do the spiritual discussion between you
and yourself and god
is i'm not done being a junkie yeah